- [Mark] All right, Heather.
Heather, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I was born in Mission Hills
in 700 Valley, California
and I
grew up 'til like sixth grade and then I
went to the High Desert Valley.
and moved back and forth from
there to Huntington Beach.
- [Mark] So California, your whole life?
- Yep.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
Did you have both your parents growing up?
- No.
So my parents divorced when I was seven
and it was like good until then, I guess.
You know,
I didn't really know any
of the stresses or anything
but they ended up divorcing or
separating when I was seven and
my mom,
she,
I don't know she had another boyfriend
and I don't know how long it was going on,
but I knew and I was six,
I don't know how to keep that secret.
And then so my dad,
he just moved to Huntington
Beach and I ended up
going with him versus my mother,
and was raised
more or less by him
and my brother was there, so,
but at that age, I kinda raised myself
cause my father was a drug user.
So,
but I...
I guess some of my...
(mumbles)
the things that I know how to do now
are because I raised myself basically.
So I guess it's like a
sink or swim situation.
It sounds shady but
in your adulthood I guess it
paid off, if you will.
- [Mark] And, how was your childhood,
any crazy views or anything like that?
- Yeah, I started using drugs and
drinking when I was 12
because I didn't know,
I didn't have anybody else to talk to,
I didn't have anybody at all.
The people that I did
pick to be, you know,
I thought were my
friends were always older
and obviously handing me,
here try this one, try that,
Yeah, okay.
And, you know, pretty soon,
I started using,
that's what my go-to was.
I don't know, even to this day
I don't know any other
way than to just go and,
you know, go back to what--
- [Mark] What drugs
were you using at that--
- Yeah,
Well, I started with marijuana,
obviously and then drinking.
And,
and then
one day the person that
I thought was going to sell me marijuana,
sold me crystal meth.
(chuckles)
That was
another,
That was a whole another,
life, different people different,
whole different life.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I didn't really have a childhood really.
I just kind of raised myself.
I don't remember even,
I remember just keeping getting
passed back and forth from my parents,
from my mom and my dad, like,
if one got tired of me then,
okay, you take her now.
You know and
I was always kind of envious of my brother
cause he got both of my parents and,
and he was 18 so
he's more well-rounded than I am.
He's got everything,
he's very put together,
he's a...
You know, he a very successful person
and so is my father but I guess,
he's a weekend warrior and
it just
to this day,
things resurface and it just kills me.
Some of the situations I
had to deal with as a child.
So I wasn't like molested,
or raped or anything like that.
Just emotional stress
and,
having to worry if,
like we'd have food in the house.
My dad made plenty of money,
but he'd go spend it.
So those stresses aren't
meant for children, you know
like the bills
or getting yourself up for school and like
not having anybody, you know, sucks.
- [Mark] And what age were
you when you left home?
- I was 17.
- [Mark] Where'd you go?
Where'd you--
- I moved to the Valley
and I became a stripper.
- [Mark] Oh, really?
- Yeah, (laughing)
Back then it wasn't like,
they're gonna cart, like
of course, they asked for your ID
and then you just give them,
you go get one on Alvaro,
(laughing) I don't know.
Or you just, you know
you just give that to them.
But yeah, I was, I
wanted to grow up so fast
because I felt like that was the only way
I was gonna have,
be able to live the life that
I wanted to live, you know.
I mean, I know my dad tried but
I guess having those stresses
he just, he's a good father but
I think he just, he went crazy.
just as much as anybody would, I guess
after, you know, that, so.
- [Mark] And working as a stripper
as a young girl,
the drugs get more heavier?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] In your life?
- And I just started using cocaine and,
I think it was ecstasy was a big thing
at the time with Xanax and,
you know, that was...
and then crystal meth obviously,
to keep the weight off and,
to be able to just go, go, go, go, go.
And then drinking a lot,
I drank a lot.
I got my first DUI when I was
19.
And that's when I got, I had,
I've lived on my driver's side window.
So...
But the life of a, you know
when we first moved down here,
we just had, we had so much money
we didn't know what to do with it.
We just go on vacations all the time,
just every single day with our
like drug dealers (laughs).
Vegas one week and then
Walt Disneyland cause we feel like it
and its was crazy.
It was crazy money.
And it was, it was a fun time
I wouldn't take it back.
But
I went through,
I saw things.
I was very shy.
I felt like I guess I was,
sheltered and I didn't
really know how to do much.
And I was just very simplistic.
Like,
I dunno just different than,
a different life, different life.
I felt like I led a whole life.
And then when I came back to,
I ended up moving
I stopped stripping one day, I just,
some guy did something
really disgusting to me,
he just grabbed me,
and like sat me on his lap
and he just like finished,
in his pants and like,
he wouldn't let me up.
And I just said,
that was the last time because
it really wasn't who I was in my,
you know, in my heart.
But, so I just quit and I moved back
to Palmdale to try to
regroup and just
maybe be, act my age, maybe have my
maybe just be able to be who I wanted,
who I was meant to be.
And I just felt like when I met,
other people my age, which was 19, I just,
I felt like I had led a whole life,
because at 15 and 16 I was in Hollywood on
Sunset Boulevard with a fake ID,
drinking with you know,
a lot of famous people and just like,
Oh, I don't ask for too much.
I just, I learned that
as long as you look cute and smile
and
maybe nod you know,
you're just,
you're in, everything will
be handed to you really.
So,
I mean I,
it was crazy.
It was insane.
- [Mark] Then after stripping
where did your life go after that?
- I,
like I said, I moved to Palmdale,
back to Palmdale cause I,
after that I just,
I had a falling out with my roommate.
She was just, she was always intoxicated.
I didn't realize how that
she even had a drug problem.
We had both, you know
you're not gonna admit that,
hey, I think we're, we got a problem here.
No, it was just every day you wake up,
you get high and get drunk
or whatever the the fuck you wanna do.
Get laid, whatever.
Anything goes.
And there's a lot of backstabbing,
a lot of conniving and,
just
debauchery.
And I...
She,
she and I just couldn't meet eye to eye.
At some point, like I was, I really
I did have like,
otherwise a little bit
morals and values and
respect and I just,
I just couldn't keep throwing,
for lack of a better
word, fucking myself off.
I wanted something different.
I wanted to be back
around my family or whatever.
And
so I moved back,
and within I think it
was like a couple months,
I ended up meeting my ex-boyfriend.
And at the pizza,
Vince's passed him pizza.
That's when I started using meth,
like full time, like every day, all day,
that was like the thing that
they did in Palmdale (laughs).
And one night I just got really drunk
and I, my daddy used to,
the reason why is because
my home life wasn't great.
Like, everybody looks at you, like,
as long as you look put together
they don't really ask,
how you're doing.
Like, they just think,
oh, she, you know, she's
always had it like that.
She's got it good.
And, blah, blah, blah,
Really I'm like this broken
little skeleton (laughs).
It's like you know, crypt-keeper,
inside.
And
I just wanting to be,
to be searching for love and all that,
acceptance, whatever.
So again, my dad, you know
he stops using drugs for the little while.
And then again, he picks it back up
and there's again these
prostitutes in my house all the time
and-and you know,
he's all,
he don't come home
and when he does come home,
he's got like this gnarly story
and he's got like,
like blood,
I just like one day he got shot in the arm
for the love of God.
I mean his whole car, it was like blood.
And I just, it scared
the daylights out of me,
but I just, I didn't wanna be home.
And when I'd come home I'd have to kick
these prostitutes and people out
and clean up, you know,
pretend like it just didn't even happen,
because that's what we did.
We just, we never talked about,
we just, (claps hands)
sweep it under the rug,
I guess if you will
and just pretend like, I didn't see that.
I didn't hear that.
I mean, I guess my dad
went through a lot but
I just,
I didn't like being home,
you know.
But I was there because
he asked me to help him,
he needed me because
for whatever reason, and I believed him.
So, and then when he'd
meet somebody eventually,
then I wouldn't be needed anymore.
He'd move out and I'd just be
left, like, okay, I guess I'll, you know
go figure something out
for myself, you know.
- [Mark] So, you have
a family of your own?
- I do,
I do.
But I,
my daughter's father, he uses
when I first moved into Kenyon he,
I met him at his house.
My friend brought me
cause he was having a barbecue.
And like, we just instantly connected.
And I think we had gotten pregnant like
a month after I met him (chuckles).
It was the best thing but,
I had been to,
I've been in and out of jail.
I got like 4 DUIs.
During that, from 19 to
27 and
did a bunch of jail time and
everything you shouldn't do, I did.
I just, I didn't know a chill button.
So when I met him,
I was thirty...
I was 29.
And like I said,
just had gotten out of jail
maybe a couple of months prior to that.
And
we just clicked, I guess,
and you know unbeknownst to me,
got pregnant within a month.
And we just decided, you know what,
he was already old, he's about,
I think about 15 years older than me.
And I was just like, well,
we're adults why don't we just,
do have the baby.
So we did.
And she's the love of my heart.
She's the light of my life but
we...
I hung in there for six years.
You know, we had a
house in Canyon Country,
pool, jacuzzi, gardener, everything.
My daughter,
very, very,
very, very lucky.
She was able, I mean,
I gave her anything she wanted,
I was with her every day.
There was nowhere I wanted to be.
I was domesticated.
I was a paralegal.
I do accounting and bookkeeping.
You know, I paid the bills,
you know I took care of her
and, you know he just,
he didn't do anything like,
most of our pictures
are of just me and her because
he never got out of bed
because he was always on drugs.
I didn't notice that,
I didn't know what he was on until
like two years later
cause I was never used to
seeing somebody on Xanax
you know, Vicodin.
I just couldn't understand why
he'd always have mood swings
and why he'd always be wanting
to lay down all the time.
So...
And he would just verbally, you know
attack me if things weren't
perfect.
And I mean perfectly,
this coffee cup better
be in the same position
as I put it the day before
and the day before, and the day before,
and the way he would do it.
If you were in the kitchen then
if he'd walk in, you'd have to walk out.
Cause otherwise he'd yell at you,
What, why are you in the kitchen?
Just, you know I cooked him
dinner every night
after an eight-hour day,
come home, take care of my baby.
I wanted to show my parents that I could,
I could be a responsible daughter.
I could have, this life that, you know
but when the doors closed they had no idea
like what it really went through.
So...
And I just, for my daughter's sake,
I never wanted her to see any
ugly
or like feel,
you know, feel like I do, you know have
two parents, at different homes.
Just, I didn't want her,
I didn't want her to go through that.
So I just stuck it out, you know?
(sniffles)
And pretty soon, you can't beat, join 'em.
So I had my breast augmentation
a year after she was born
and they gave me Vicodin.
And that was probably
the beginning of the
end.
You know I just,
I drank still and didn't
see a problem with it.
Usually, she'd go to my mom's house
every other weekend or whatever.
So me and her dad we'd just,
party like if we were
fricking 16 years old
and just be doing the most.
And you know, by Sunday,
clean up our act and make sure
pick up the baby yeah like,
nothing happened.
But
it was just a crazy,
he was very different,
he was just into the drug scene
and knew a lot of bad shitty people.
And,
You I just, I was...
Like I said, you can't
beat them, join them.
I started this job
in North Hollywood and
it was one of the best jobs I did have.
And it paid the most
but it was just very stressful
and I couldn't handle it.
So I just started using Vicodin.
Like one one and then,
next thing you know I'm asking for two,
and the next thing you know
I'm asking for Xanax
and the next thing, you know
I'm not doing my job (laughs).
And then I ended up in,
I ended up taking my car out one night
and
crashed it.
And I, and it was parked in my front yard
and I didn't even know
how the hell it got there.
And I thought I had was over those days,
like, oh, I'm not drinking-driving
ever again, you know.
And I said, holy shit,
And I said you know what?
I gotta do something about this.
And I just, cause
like I said, in my family,
you don't talk about
what's really going on and you just,
unless you get caught of course.
You're like, Oh God, oh shit.
But I just called my mom and was like,
I need to go to rehab.
I'd been to rehab when I was
15 because of crystal meth.
But, and 'cause I got
kicked out of high school.
So,
I just,
I have this just way about it,
I just like to do what I want when I want.
And I don't care what I'm,
what I'm supposed to do
oh, this is what I'm doing.
But when I became a mother, like I just,
I did everything the right way
and it still ended up,
it's such an ugly path.
I'm still struggling with that.
Every, every second, you know it just,
I hate being away from her.
And that's the reason why I can't
get my shit together because it's like,
there's no happiness, there's no
it's not living without her.
But,
I just, I,
I was accused of
I was drunk, or I got I was drinking,
and her dad
had accused me of
like driving drunk with her,
like drugging, I don't know.
He made a report, basically.
And the cops came
(sniffling)
and
it was like the ugliest thing.
I ended up getting arrested.
I then,
as I'm getting arrested
it's like, the CPS,
was already informed.
Met me at the station
and
told me, well, since
you're her only guardian
guess like your daughter's
not gonna be with you anymore.
You just go to your parents.
You lost custody.
You're losing custody right now.
So, but six hours later I was led out
and everything was, straightened out.
And I was, you know
they were able to see that
I didn't do any other thing but,
because CPS already got involved,
I'm riding this,
this wave.
And I,
so
I'm doing everything that
they wanted me to do.
I'm thinking in two months or
whenever the court it was,
I think maybe two or three
months down the road,
she's gonna come back home.
And every night I'm telling her, you know
at this point they made, they also made me
move out of my mom's house.
Because I moved us to there
because I couldn't be with him anymore.
They made me move out of my mom's house
cause I couldn't be,
I couldn't spend the night at her house
because of Ashley was there
And trying to tell your
daughter every single,
I mean, I've told her,
she's five years old.
She's sleeping with me.
Trying to tell her and rock her to sleep
and tell her, you know, I'm sorry.
I can't, I gotta go.
Mommy has to leave.
Watching her cry.
And my mom crying.
It tore my,
it ripped my heart out.
And,
in the court,
three months later, they're like
just go and do the course that
they want me to do.
Of course they, it wasn't good enough.
So there was later I'm expected
here to be able to come
home and tell my baby,
okay, it is another
couple of weeks, you know?
And
they say, well,
no she's not gonna come
home with you, you know.
You didn't do this,
or you gotta do this, this and that.
So,
I lost it.
I just lost it.
It's painful you know.
It's painful.
And
I mean, people, they don't understand.
I just, I lost...
I just couldn't keep my shit together.
And so one night,
you know,
I'm drinking
cause I don't know what the
fuck else to do with myself.
And my friend's doing it, you know
goes and gets some heroin and I'm like,
okay, cool, you're getting it anyway,
Like I don't need it.
All of a sudden I'm like, well,
well I wanna try it out
and then I see how messed he gets
I say, well shit,
he's pretty numb.
Maybe I'd like to try that.
Okay, well you need to smoke it,
No, no, no,
I wanna do it like you,
I'm doing it like you.
So he tries to give me this speech.
I'm like, yeah, yeah, save it.
Who cares, I'm not gonna end up like you.
I'm not like that,
it's not gonna happen to me.
And, Jesus Christ, I think
I was using like two grams of heroin a day
driving from Palmdale,
I don't even think I took a shower,
changed my clothes or brush my hair
for like three,
the first, like three weeks for sure.
I think I was just...
A slave, you get up,
you go to sleep, pass
out 'cause you're high,
you get up,
and you just go to the dealer right away.
I mean, I had really nice bags.
I had you know money saved.
I had a car, I had everything.
And by the time that was all over I,
this is where I've ended up.
Like, I cleaned up my act a few times
but I just keep getting
involved with these
people that just are abusive
and cruel.
And they take everything,
you know, they build you up, you know
in the beginning, you just believe them,
and you're like okay, you know?
And then all of a sudden,
they're calling, you know
they're putting their hands on you
and beating you and,
these awful names,
calling these awful names,
cheating on you,
just taking you know
what's left of,
what's left of me basically
and just fucking trashing it.
So I just...
I just wanted to die.
Like I just been,
I'm like, you know
I just got into that mind frame like,
who cares if I'm gonna be gone?
Like, you know what I mean?
Maybe my daughter would be better off.
Like, and you know,
I thought that my daughter
would be better off
if I don't talk, if I don't call
cause I don't wanna upset her,
make her think about me.
So I've...
I grow estranged for a couple months.
And it's is not right, you know.
But, my mom didn't want me to come see her
and then knock-up,
It was just,
such a, it's like such bullshit really.
It's your guilt keeps you
sick and it keeps you
away from the people
that you love the most.
Because you don't know what to say.
How many excuses,
you don't know what to say,
there's no excuse in the world
why you're not there with your baby
and why you're not
working on yourself to get it back there.
But when you're on the street,
and you're walking around at 3:00 AM
and you know nobody's thinking about you,
you're just on your own.
It's a pretty fucked up lonely feeling.
And you know,
for me, I can't just ride it out.
I gotta, I need something
to make me feel better.
Cause that's all that I,
that's all that I know.
Every person I relied on left or lied or
did me some way or another
you know even my parents.
At some point, it's like
if I can't trust them,
who can I trust?
Nobody really.
And everyone pretends that they're
your friend and they're
nice and they're gonna
do this, that and the other,
but really they just want, you know
they want what they want.
And
I've had to put my self aside in a,
for like basic human necessities
which somebody shouldn't have to do
for just to take a shower, whatever
You know just,
stupid little things that
people take advantage of.
Or I don't know, just
if I had, I could have
gone somewhere, I just
because of this situation,
I'll never be the same.
Like I'll never, I could never go back
to the person that I was.
There is such a difference
in pictures from
before when I was with my baby
until now I'm just like this.
I don't even look the same.
And I've just seen so many things
that somebody just doesn't ever wanna see.
And I mean, it is ugly.
You just, you don't know
how ugly the world is until
you have nothing
and you have too much
pride to ask for stuff.
But-but,
you find yourself
now prostituting herself because
nobody else is gonna give you money.
And you know,
you don't wanna work
because you want to do drugs all day.
cause you, but you don't
wanna really do drugs.
You're just trying to be normal again
It's this fucking sick cycle,
but it'll end up, you know
it'll end you up on the
wrong side of the tracks.
And unfortunately,
I was living in Laughlin and
I was in the same shit
there as I'm doing here.
And I just,
I try to,
one day I wake up and
I wanna save the world
the next day I'm just like, fuck it.
I don't care.
I'm just gonna ODI and end it all.
And a couple of weeks ago,
somebody did give me
fentanyl and I did die.
And
you know, you don't realize
like once that happens,
it makes you take life
a little more seriously.
Maybe I don't wanna die.
Maybe I do wanna do the
right thing, you know.
I just got into an argument with Jonathan
and,
which was my ex-boyfriend now,
I just got into an argument with him and
it would have been the
last time he talked to me
it would just, last time
anybody would see me,
but my family doesn't reach out to me.
Like they turned their back right now.
And I guess they think that I should
go to rehab or whatever, but, you know
it's like,
I don't know why they,
why they're just so judgmental.
They don't understand like,
I like literally had a mental breakdown
and nobody's asking me,
if I'm, you know, if I'm okay
like they just carry on like,
Oh, well, like, you know it just sucks.
So, it just keeps me, in the streets more.
I mean, I'm not trying
to feel sorry for myself
but I guess that's
really what's happening.
I can't seem to do this sober.
And I don't know when
something's gonna change.
I mean, yeah, I could go and I could
pretend to like somebody,
because that's all
these men want, you know
probably a pretty girl and you know,
for basically you to smile and nod and
I could have you know,
I could have a house
and I can have the car.
I can have everything.
But I don't, I'm just I'm sick of,
I'm just sick of doing that.
I'm sick of pretense.
I don't...
I wanna be happy and that's
not happiness for me you know.
But I don't know I just,
I have goals, but I don't know.
At some point you just,
nothing ever goes right.
I'm a great starter, but you know
just can't seem to finish anything.
And so, said boyfriend cheating on me and
like three days ago, he
kicks me out of my house
and,
first of all
he's sleeping with the girl
downstairs we had roommates
and looks me in the eye and tells me
I would never do that
and la-la-la.
And we got in an argument and he just
he just didn't want to be with me anymore.
So he had the manager kicked me out cause
that's the girl that
he's screwing, cousin.
So of course he's going
to have loyalty to her
and kicks me out.
And so I ended up back here,
you know cause I came here two months ago,
then we got a place and then, you know
and then I'm here again.
I mean, these people, some of them
they're the most generous, beautiful
souls I've ever met.
Like give me more than my family.
They feed me, show me love
don't judge me, you know
just took me in and helped me.
But then there's ones that, you know
they make you think they're gonna do that
and then all of a sudden you're
you're in somebodies apartment with eight
dudes and you're just like, holy shit,
how did I get here?
Cause there's, you don't know, you know
they already have a plan
for you before you're even
five you know, five feet away.
So,
it's a learning lesson for sure.
And you can't trust
everybody that you want to.
And there's a lot of
wolves in sheep's clothing as they say.
But I, you know
there's things that go on here that
I would never even think possible that
I never thought I would witness.
Like there was
just bad, bad things, you know?
And--
- [Mark] What's the
worst thing you've seen?
- Murder.
Somebody got murdered.
And he was screaming for help.
And I, and there's nothing
that you can do because
you don't wanna put yourself
out because you know
like you don't wanna,
get killed yourself
just for like trying to,
and what could you, what
could I have done, really?
Here's another two men, like,
he was taken from his tent.
I was next door waiting
for my friend to come back.
And all I could hear was, you know
his blood-curdling scream.
Like
"I don't know, please no",
And,
"help me"
in the distance and,
and as I was listening, you know it stops
And you just,
and I didn't have a phone on me to call
and I'm just going, this is not real,
this is not really happening.
This is fake.
And then, so I, the next
I'm like shaking like a leaf and I just,
Oh my God,
I can't believe that
there's that this goes on.
But I mean, they say, they talk about it,
like it's yeah, it's happened
But you really don't think
it's ever gonna happen
around you or in front of you.
Like, this is just for
the movies or whatever
dramatic, you know?
But no, it happened.
And then I see his picture on the,
on the door of like these places
I'm like, holy shit.
Like,
like I don't know who did that...
This you know, to him,
but I know that he's never coming back.
I asked one of the
you know, neighbors,
by the tent where I was at.
And I said, like, you see,
do you think this is what happens?
Oh yeah, that is, yeah.
He never came back.
And I think you don't
know what somebody did to,
nobody deserves it,
but you don't know what somebody
did to get to that point.
I mean, totally.
It really scares you into just
wanting to run away but
where do I run away?
I have no home.
You wanna go home, but where is that? So--
- [Mark] So, you're at Skid row now,
where are you living, you have a tent?
- No, I have friends that I stay with.
Like, one day I'll stay with this friends
the next, you know, it just depends.
- [Mark] So you just find a place
to crash every night?
- Yeah.
I mean, everybody, when
you're a pretty I guess
well, they think I'm pretty
and you know just,
my good looks get me somewhere
- [Mark] Are sexual favors
part of your business?
- No.
Well, not with my friends, no.
But even though I'm sure
it's like an undertone
it's mostly probably expected,
but
I try not to
to think about it.
You know, sometimes you just
gotta do what you gotta do.
- [Mark] And what do you do
to support your drug habit?
- I don't usually pay for drugs,
but if I have to,
I prostitute myself,
I've been,
I've been prostituting myself
for
a month now I guess.
It's,
it's not who I am.
I just kind of separate myself from that,
from that person and I just try to
pretend like it didn't happen.
Like I got money made,
like, I can just, you know
I'm sure it'll catch up with me someday,
but right now I'm just trying to
get through the day, like.
I've never stole anything in my life
and all of a sudden I'm
having to steal things
because otherwise you know,
I'm not gonna have it and I need it.
You know, like I said, it's
just, it's a, it's a shitty
it's a shitty life, you know?
And I just,
I need to,
I need to start, doing the right thing and
everyone's like, you need to go to rehab.
And I just, I feel like
I'm not ready yet you know.
I just, unfortunately, I'm not...
- [Mark] Is your daughter with her father?
- Yeah, she's with her dad
and with my parents.
And it just seems like
every time I try my hardest,
it just there's something there
to stop it and it's like,
what the fuck am I supposed to do?
Like, I've done everything you know.
I just don't know.
I don't, I just--.
- [Mark] What do you think the core
of your addiction is?
Is it something that happened
early in childhood, is--
- I just think it's abandonment issues
and it's not feeling like
I was important enough to,
you know
never being good enough.
Always pushed to the side like,
you know like
what I have to say is
not important to anybody
and nobody gives a shit about
your feelings, you know.
Always having to rely on myself
because I never had anybody to talk to.
Like I see these families and
I'm just so envious, you know.
And I just, I tell you know,
little girl, whatever kid,
just be your age you know.
Just live your,
you know live you childhood.
Like, don't be so quick
to grow up like you know.
Cause you definitely could just,
it goes so fast.
And
I just wish that,
for my daughter's sake,
I you know,
I did cute things there
to keep her you know.
I just hope that
her dad and my parents you know they,
they do say--
- [Mark] Your daughter is seven now?.
- Six, she's gonna be seven
It breaks my heart
I wasn't able to be there for her birthday
or Christmas, and I just wanna I mean,
there's nothing I could
say that would ever,
you know--
- [Mark] What do you think people
- People think?
- [Mark] That are not addicts,
don't understand about addiction?
- It's because we're,
it's emotional damage.
It's PTSD really.
It's just as bad maybe
if you'd gone to war.
People put up with things
and see things that
they just, it fucking shocks you
and
it's so
upsetting to you,
to your soul that, you
know, you block it out
you block it out, block it out, and then,
as you get older things
start re-surfacing.
I mean the song play or
you'll smell something and then just
(fingers snaps).
All of a sudden you're inch,
up shit creek, no battle.
And
I think that
a lot of people
they're trying to self-medicate as well.
For my depression, I use heroin.
For weight loss, I use meth.
That's about it you know.
When you're addicted to heroin
you're just trying to get enough
so you could feel normal.
- [Mark] That's the same
principle as alcohol, isn't it?
- Yeah! same goes
- It is not different?
right.
Because it's anxiety.
I think a lot of people,
if they were given the right medication
and they took it the right way
and they were,
I think they'd be a whole,
in a whole different world.
Because there are very
good people out here
but they're also, you know
the animals and the
bad, the bad, bad, bad.
But, for the most part, I
just think that you know,
people are just judgemental.
It's okay to (fingers snaps)
oh, well, you're a drug addict.
Well, I wonder why, like, you know
it's emotional pain, I think,
and it's anxiety and just self-medication.
Self-medicating.
I don't think that they,
they wanted to grow up
and say, and, you know
be talking to themselves, you know
on the corner in their tent.
Like, I don't think that they wanted that.
Personally, you know shit went down and
they got fuck, their brain,
you know (beeps) like
you know,
did a,
a 180.
As I'm, you know,
as here, I understand that
And I can, I can relate and I don't judge
and I accept everybody,
but before and unless
you're in that situation
unless you've gone through it,
you're gonna, you know
you're very quick to just be like,
Oh, what a fucking loser?
Like, I'll never be like that.
Well, hopefully, you're not like that.
But if you do end up like that,
you know,
he just,
maybe I,
I don't know.
I think, I think it's sad
because they're the first like I said
they're the first people
that will give you their
shirt off their back
versus someone in you know,
a family member even,
a friend.
I just think they know what it's like.
You know they...
You know, you never
know when it's gonna be
your first day on the street.
Like you're just supposed
to figure this out.
Like you know,
people are so scared to
death but I think that
once you're able to survive
and I think there's a lot of finessing
a lot of manipulation,
a lot of bartering.
I think that you could survive anywhere.
And I think it's, it made me stronger
and I've able to find who I am.
Maybe I needed that a little bit.
Cause you know,
when it going from like having stuff to
to not having it and being
able to still be happy
and survive and laugh through it,
you know says something you know.
I don't know what that is
but there's a lesson
learned and I'm grateful.
I'm grateful to be able to like,
I can be, you know a chameleon really like
be with people that have money,
people that don't have money.
I can fit in with everybody.
Cause I've been in each stage.
I feel like.
So,
I guess that's a
you know one-up, I guess.
But--
- [Mark] Do you think
there's a chance that
you might not get out of here?
- No, I don't know.
Shit, I ever thought about that.
Well, I don't know.
Some days I just wanna
shoot myself in the face honestly.
I just, sometimes I
walk around and I just,
you know these people
it's like the second coming of Jesus.
I think I'm like the only
white girl here (chuckles).
I don't know.
The other ones are a little crazy.
But sometimes I just I'm like,
where the, where am I going?
What should I do with myself?
Why am I not going back to my career or
or my,
trying to work towards my family or why,
you know, why this, why that?
And then all of a sudden
I find myself high again
and well, you know, I'll go tomorrow.
I'll do this tomorrow,
tomorrow, tomorrow, tomorrow.
Well, I don't know.
And, like I said, a couple weeks ago,
I didn't know if tomorrow would have came.
I ODed and I,
and died and,
luckily the people
that were around me cared about me and
they gave me Narcan
and I took two of them.
And then they, they did call 911.
And even though they had guns
and this and that and the other,
they didn't, they put themselves
aside to save my life.
And for that, I'll always be grateful.
So you just never know.
You just never know.
I think it's important to
just live your life you know,
and just be as happy as you can
and do the right thing by
people and you know, and
and, love more than, give love more than,
Hey, you know at least try not to,
you know,
be an asshole
(chuckles) really like you know,
I think that I'm a giver.
I just, I love to see if you can make
you can be kind to somebody that you know,
it could make their day
or their life, you know
even taking a couple of
minutes out of your time
to make them smile and laugh
because they're always on edge you know,
wondering if someone's
gonna get over on them,
you know its, its,
it's something that you
know is invaluable, I think.
And they'll remember
you by that, you know?
So I think you should be
remembered by you know,
something good versus, (laughs)
versus being an asshole
(laughs) to people.
- [Mark] All right Heather
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Yeah. Thank you, thank you.
- [Mark] Good luck in
getting back together with your daughter.
- Yes, thank you.
- [Mark] Thanks.